a kid [ __ ] were doing the Jimmy
tour-de-force call first can we go talk
to him I have the perfect way to do it
[ __ ] loser I'll look at that booty
though you know that booty is just a
vine all right i'm flying out there why
there she does so slow come on bro
okay okay come on I'm on Jays ass
I can't really get there but it's
[ __ ] like pulling teeth
come on
uh
mm-hmm that booty that booty is just up
line you [ __ ] it a salad out of that
okay I can't [ __ ] just chop it uh
yeah bye bye oh yeah cash [ __ ] cops
all right calling my allies your arm I'm
making a living to our problem okay what
the hell is that focuses age hop in a
wheel on the way to play 2k 10 this is
supposed to help us well yeah singer is
he think I said songs with your car
mechanics be free and Jonna giving us a
chance to reason with him you got to be
kidding and while we going to Planet
saints today is Fan Appreciation Day at
all those locations dad may turn up
looking to reconnect with the change uh
yeah the problem is the crowd what about
will have to keep them from trucking him
henkes begun my own king yet creation it
could be able to hold up any crazy and
without killing them Jimmy oh that's
harming the peace son you know what fine
try it
shut wow what a [ __ ] shark I don't
[ __ ] genius here we are time to
serenade gat I hate you right now
wait what am I supposed to do oh these
guys I don't look like how to get rid of
ok I was shut this one up there there
okay yes is this guy the [ __ ] is this
some weird ass [ __ ] that's all I gotta
say yea big highbrows be kind yeah I
wanna have to bail [ __ ] out
I can't oh [ __ ] they won't let me do
that that's my snap her neck
doesn't shoot far who's left oh here we
go who are you let's get moving Pierce
uh I don't think this is a particularly
good you're checking of the crowd and
get really i mean like a mission finally
find their friend put the group in high
spirits period kinging would work
custody and beg him by Judith trulia
took the fans at bay we could drink of
their leader guiding them all [ __ ] on
this kind of fear as they drove a
thought of all the good they
accomplished together
ok
u.s.
but chef chef
where is he ours out here in your deck
naked I think nudist was their lost
friend and we're happy to heat him alive
and well ah [ __ ] did you do to get holy
[ __ ] Jimmy remember the plan get him
calm before getting near him I think
that's why I say here's oh that's him
yes
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] him threw a chair at me
cats [ __ ] yes
[ __ ] days
someone singing oh it's thing
where is a wow what is that a [ __ ]
helicopter
[ __ ] I just forget I asked
[ __ ]
[ __ ] this is actually getting a little
hard
make sure he gets all right I'm getting
[ __ ] up oh come on I'll track him
how the [ __ ] do I turn ok ok I can oh
[ __ ] fine tag he's tagged the name with
a [ __ ] captain Oh God one hit game at
a bar gaddis we knew the back there we
rethought Tigers got locked up keeping
in his life we have to keep our
it's all right Johnny I'm here I really
hate you both right now the bees will
work on ghat right thank you I hope so
[ __ ] an icon this [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I didn't
say the car he [ __ ] sucked the car I
kept it in the [ __ ] car ROFL grand
chase s how about the [ __ ] I don't wipe
that said I thought I can't lie we had
to keep our wits up
okay hey by this batch it's all right
Johnny I'm here I really hate you both
right now the bees will work on cat
right yo I hope so if they don't Pierce
is in trouble he is getting stung up hey
does not like it if he's like right here
the ravings either tormented man that's
like he'll bat what is it oh it would
take something more powerful the most
powerful feeling ball nah oh [ __ ] it's
this [ __ ] you did it who [ __ ] did it
she's one true love I couldn't let him
live without her Pierce on it it's
actually working kid you got lucky here
sure dude we can take them both home
wait we hear that sound I should have
known name it was the sound of doom on
our doorstep oh now we gotta find
something bigger to stop gasps he was
hard to control when he wasn't a
rampaging clones lucky for him I had a
good day okay for Miss know where I bet
it's been over yeah toward the boss I
think I'm on ebay
dips out for her Amish